bon allez vous nous faire pardonner vous
voulez quelque chose d'un peu salée
c'est hyper sympa je suis pas un monstre
à fuir vous aviez fage et s'il vous
trouvez quelque chose voilà je louvre
alors là bien sûr c'est pour vous
longtemps je peux pas parler non je vais
faire une
annonce je te rappelle alors grégoire
c'est quoi ce film dans lequel c'est la
nouvelle comédie de quentin dupieux et
qui je sais pas quel réalisateur
j'imagine je pense ça parle beaucoup
c'est un flic qui interroge un suspect
toute une nuit
ça va mal tourner et un meurtre ouais le
titre de fils au poste au dos la
nouvelle comédie
2 quant à lui qu' avec le noir l'unique
benoît forme
mark xiii à la liste de moustier
philippe duquesne et il plaît à d'autres
acteurs amusant amusant du méjean
bientôt je me sens ouais bientôt 111
euros
[Musique]